hemos recorrido un camino largo desde
que empezamos a hablar del tracto
gastrointestinal
desde nuestra cavidad oral ahora que
hemos hecho todo el recorrido es hora de
hablar sobre la parte final de nuestro
tracto gastrointestinal el intestino
grueso o colon el recto y el ano
acerquémonos y centrémonos en lo que
sucede después de que se absorbe la
comida en el intestino delgado parece
que la comida pasa al intestino grueso
como puedes ver aquí el intestino grueso
es más corto que el intestino delgado
que acabamos de ver comienza justo aquí
y continúa hasta este punto el final del
intestino delgado es la válvula y los
'call la válvula y léo se cae y ese es
el punto donde comienza nuestro
intestino grueso y esto tiene sentido
porque recuerda la última parte del
intestino delgado se llama y león' la
primera parte de nuestro intestino
grueso
se llama ciego ciego puedes notar esta
pequeña parte con forma de cola que está
aquí no parece que haga mucho cierto
parece una estructura sin función y de
esta es una de las causas más comunes de
cirugía en el tracto gastrointestinal es
el apéndice esta es la parte donde
comienza nuestro intestino grueso a esta
parte del intestino grueso a medida que
asciende se le llama colon derecho pero
más específicamente se le llama colon
ascendente y hace exactamente lo que su
nombre sugiere asciende va desde el
punto inferior del abdomen a un punto
superior luego corre transversalmente a
la parte del intestino grueso que
continúa después del colon ascendente se
le llama el colon transverso otro gran
nombre eso describe cómo funciona colon
transverso porque corre transversalmente
a continuación llegamos a esta parte si
llamamos a esta parte ascendente
entonces supongo que podríamos llamar a
esta parte colon descendente nombres
geniales en el intestino grueso o colon
este es el colon descendente hace lo que
dice desciende a la última parte de
nuestro intestino grueso donde ya no
estamos descendiendo pero estamos dando
vuelta como
una forma de s se le llama colon
sigmoide sigmoide porque tiene forma de
s
este es el colon sigmoide que esto que
el intestino grueso es responsable de
absorber hagamos una lista que es lo más
importante que absorbe y cuál es el
impacto lo primero en lo que debes
pensar es en el agua el agua es lo más
importante que absorbe el intestino
grueso y es muy importante para regular
el resultado que vamos a obtener al
final aquí abajo en el ano ahora qué
pasa se absorbe muy poca agua muy poca
agua eso significa que lo que sale
tenderá a ser más aguado cierto porque
no se absorbe en el cuerpo eso es lo que
causa la diarrea diarrea porque las
heces van a tener demasiada agua ahora
pensemos en el caso opuesto qué pasa se
absorbe demasiada agua si se absorbe
demasiada agua las heces ya no serán tan
suaves el agua como podemos pensar es el
componente de las heces que las hace
relativamente más suaves así que si se
absorbe demasiada agua en el intestino
grueso o colon
tendremos lo contrario de la diarrea y
nos vamos a extrañar el estreñimiento
que tampoco es bueno el intestino grueso
es muy importante para regular
exactamente cuánta agua necesita ser
eliminada otra de las cosas que podemos
mencionar en este punto es la enfermedad
conocida como cólera estoy segura de que
has oído hablar de eso antes es una
terrible enfermedad en la que una
bacteria ataca ciertos receptores o
ciertas proteínas que están en el
revestimiento intestinal específicamente
en el intestino grueso eso significa que
se empieza a perder una tremenda
cantidad de fluido que finalmente
conduce a la muerte por deshidratación
lo interesante es que si puedes mantener
a una persona hidratada por el tiempo
suficiente su tracto gastrointestinal
superará a la bacteria si puedes
mantener a una persona hidratada
mientras tiene cólera puedes hacer que
pase la enfermedad y sobreviva otra cosa
importante de la que deberíamos hablar
que se absorben en el intestino grueso
son iones inorgánicos hablamos de ellos
antes cuando discutimos sobre el
intestino delgado
estos incluyen cosas como sodio o
potasio y recuerda que el sodio había
sido absorbido como un mecanismo de
transporte con otras cosas como
aminoácidos para ayudar a su absorción y
eso ocurre en menor medida en el
intestino grueso ahora una de las cosas
interesantes que surgen a raíz de esto
es que si te fijas el intestino grueso
no es el único lugar donde se absorbe el
agua y los iones inorgánicos como el
sodio y el cloruro de potasio tampoco lo
es el intestino delgado de hecho el
órgano más responsable para la absorción
de agua y de iones inorgánicos es el
riñón por eso si perdemos el intestino
grueso por completo por algún tipo de
accidente o enfermedad como la
enfermedad de crohn o colitis ulcerosa
uno de los tratamientos para la colitis
ulcerosa es la colectomía total donde se
quita todo el colon y ya no se tiene ese
proceso inflamatorio no se podrá
absorber agua o iones inorgánicos en el
intestino grueso
pero los riñones pueden cumplir con esta
función
ahora otra cosa interesante que voy a
mencionar sobre el intestino grueso es
que es una rica fuente de
microorganismos microorganismos como las
bacterias esto es un poco raro porque la
pregunta podría ser porque tenemos
bacterias en nuestro colon cuál es el
propósito las bacterias en el colon en
realidad ayudan en la digestión de
nutrientes que no podemos hacer por
falta de enzimas ayudan en la digestión
de carbohidratos principalmente y este
es un proceso significativo leí en
alguna parte que alrededor del 5% de las
heces al final están compuestas de
microorganismos como bacterias y son muy
importantes para digerir cosas como los
carbohidratos pondré carbohidratos aquí
entre paréntesis y a menudo los
subproductos que se obtienen son cosas
como el metano ch4 y el sulfuro de
hidrógeno tal vez no hayas pensado de
esta manera pero en realidad tiene
sentido el metano es algo que causa
muchas flatulencias y el sulfuro de
hidrógeno es algo que huele terrible y
un alimento que a menudo comemos que
tiene mala reputación
son los frijoles que son bastante ricos
en carbohidratos y que no somos capaces
de absorber porque nos faltan las
enzimas los microorganismos del
intestino grueso en realidad hacen la
mayor parte de la digestión de los
carbohidratos que hay en los frijoles
probablemente hayas escuchado lo
siguiente frijoles frijoles buenos para
el corazón
cuanto más comes más metano y sulfuro de
hidrógeno produces muy bien suficientes
gases
hablemos finalmente de la última parte
del tracto gastrointestinal ahora que
hemos pasado por el intestino grueso el
siguiente lugar al que iremos es el
recto el recto no es responsable de
ninguna absorción o descomposición la
función principal del recto es el
almacenamiento realmente no pensamos en
eso pero es una parte muy importante del
tracto gastrointestinal porque una vez
que se han procesado los alimentos se ha
absorbido toda el agua y finalmente se
tiene el producto de desecho que se va a
llevar al baño no quieres que salga de
inmediato cierto deseas retenerlo hasta
que sea más apropiado expulsar
y el recto es clave para esto porque va
a aferrarse a las heces hasta que sea el
momento apropiado para llegar al baño
qué pasa con la última parte de nuestro
tracto gastrointestinal el ano el ano
está compuesto por 12 esfínteres como
recordarás en la discusión sobre el
esófago los esfínteres son músculos que
cierran un agujero hay dos esfínteres
que son responsables del ano el esfínter
anal interno y el esfínter anal externo
el esfínter anal interno está compuesto
de músculo liso el esfínter anal externo
que envuelve al esfínter anal interno
está compuesto de músculo esquelético
que controlamos el músculo liso está
bajo control involuntario cuando hay
heces en el recto empujan el esfínter
anal interno que se relajara se abrirá y
permitirá que las heces se muevan hacia
adelante ahora eso no significa que todo
sale de inmediato porque hay un esfínter
anal externo que está bajo nuestro
control pero finalmente al llegar al
baño es hora de relajar ese esfínter
anal externo
y liberar la comida que comimos en el
primer vídeo
y finalmente nos sentimos aliviados